well good evening and welcome to the
Tattered Cover bookstore thank you for
coming and thank you for supporting our
bookstore and our events we really
appreciate it
and a special welcome tonight to
c-span's book TV and to all the audience
members here in Denver tonight it's my
pleasure to introduce Roberta price who
will discuss her extraordinary book
where for know a memoir of life in the
counterculture it was published by the
University of Massachusetts in the
summer of 1969 Roberta and her partner
David made their way to Libre Colorado
one of the many new-age communes that
had just begun in the 1960s this is the
story of the seven years they spent in
where Fano or orphan valley in this
countercultural environment Roberta and
David learned to build houses fix cars
and many other things and they met a
variety of interesting people along the
way including Abbie Hoffman Allen
Ginsberg and Baba Ram Dass Roberta is a
writer and a practicing attorney
specializing in intellectual property
values and rights she now resides in
Albuquerque please welcome Roberta price
thank you it's great to be in Colorado
again thank you for choosing to spend
the inauguration of my book with me
there are a number of people from the
where for know in the audience and I was
just thinking maybe they could just
stand up
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for coming I thought I'd just
read a little bit from the prologue of
the book then show a few slides don't
like those slideshows when people are
looking at their watches and then
perhaps read a sort of humorous piece
because humour is always good especially
on Inauguration days last night I had a
dream about a dream it was 1974 the
Thanksgiving feast at the red rockers a
time when the hippy population of the
where phono Valley had swelled from the
first six at Libre in 1968 to more than
300 of us we were at Libre the red
rockers the Triple A the order B's farm
archuleta Ville we were in the tiny
towns of Gardner Red Wing malachite and
Pharisee de we were by the Butte in the
Valley Center up the canyons on the high
mountain meadows and ridges on both
sides in Adobe's geodesic domes log
cabins and shacks studded all over the
where phenom the weather was cold and
gray threatening snow and that year even
the red rockers don't 60-foot dome
couldn't accommodate the circle we
traditionally made before Thanksgiving
dinner I don't know who got the idea
first or whether we all just saw that we
had to go outside to get in a circle by
the time I was headed out of the dome
others were yelling everybody outside
we poured out without our coats some
stumbling stoned or drunk already
dressed in our holiday best fringes and
silks and Velvets and satin cowboy
shirts and hand sewn leathers forming a
circle in the Red Rock Canyon meadow
down from the dome looking down the slot
of the canyon you could only see one or
two of the mountains in the Sangre de
coeur
to arrange but since David and I had
lived high up on the ridge at Libre for
four years it was easy to envision the
rest of the mountains marching across
the curved horizon even though our view
was cut off by the canyon walls the
outline of those mountains on the rim of
the world was etched in our heads by
then behind us was the huge white
geodesic dome dwarfed by the deep red
cliffs of the canyon behind it the
generators were still running and a
tajmahal record was playing inside there
we were the wind blowing us and swirling
our hair and scarves our shawls and
skirts and fringes whipping our
bell-bottoms against the bones of our
legs and we held hands and looked at
each other and grinned in the dream
people move more gracefully and
soundlessly than they did when it
actually happened but I still heard the
wind blowing down the canyon behind us
from the top of green horn and the
laughter in the circle that was so
fragile so vivid and tattered in that
geography in the dream I saw how young
we all looked though I didn't notice at
the time David must have been on one
side of me and I don't remember who was
on the other we'd split some windowpane
acid with Henry when we got to the Red
Rocks one dose three ways or maybe it
was one of the thousands of tiny orange
tabs and the two quart canning jar that
owlsley the greatest pure acid chemist
of them all sent Libre as a commune
warming gift in 1968 but I'm pretty sure
those had all been gobbled up by then it
hadn't come on yet but my mouth was dry
my palms sweaty my heart beating harder
and I was either anticipating or just
beginning to feel those electric surging
sensual waves which flow up your spine
sprouting into chemically-induced
blossoms of enlightenment my Pentax pot
Matic hung from my neck my arms crossed
over its straps on my chest and
of our arms crossed our chest as we held
hands around the circle and I mostly
remember and therefore dreamed about the
people on the other side Winnie and Mary
red rocker Trixie
Lars and Linda Bella who had her blouse
on which was remarkable because she
always took it off at parties Steve in
his handmade deerskin pants and shirt
with a deep leather laced v-neck showing
the distinct cleft of a smooth chest
muzzles some are dead now and some are
gone by then
but last night they were back in that
circle nobody not even Peter or Dean
tried to make a speech we kept smiling
and laughing at each other although our
teeth were starting to chatter someone
maybe Peter yelled thank you then more
of a shouted thank you into the wind and
we dropped hands and ran towards each
other
boots crunching in the old snow the
circle collapsing inwards my camera
knocking against my chest as I ran at
the center as close together as we could
get we hugged one another and laughed
and cried at the same time in the dream
there were none of the difficulties
between David and me that day I felt the
same vague disconnection I felt back
then as I hugged some of the people who
grabbed me and I was surprised I didn't
know the names of some I embraced my
camera hurt my chest when I pressed
against someone too hard I never took a
picture it was impossible to capture
part of me was too involved to take
pictures well part of me was too
detached or already too stoned
then all of us turned streaming back to
the dome and the plank and sawhorse
serving tables the tables were laden
with elk roasts and wild turkey poached
from the National Forest our gardens
last sweet winter squashes all sorts of
grains and vegetables and homemade
breads and rolls the smart ones headed
for the dessert table first to get the
white sugar and chocolate desserts they
disappeared quickly
leaving only healthy desserts pies with
organic tooth breaking totally
whole-grain crusts and natural fruit
fillings so much better for you but
never sweet enough when I woke up today
I lay in the sunlight thinking about my
dream and the pilgrims first
Thanksgiving at our Thanksgiving we were
thankful though not to puritanical and
the only Indians there were one-legged
John Pedro and his scrawny son midge and
maybe one or two others from the Native
American church from Oklahoma
I thought about Sol paradise and Dean
Moriarty driving south from Denver and
on the road and the familial bond of
their manic journey our roads had ended
in the where phono the orphan Valley and
Kerouac was our John the Baptist
although I doubt he did vision dust
trying to take root in the arid rocky
meadows of the mountains he drove past
unroot to Mexico a generation before I
thought about Dylan resting on the
all-night train going west dreaming
about himself and the first few friends
he had who never thought that their road
would shatter and split whose chances
were really a million to one then at
first I didn't know why I thought a
virginia woolf the waves the chapter
about an afternoon after world war one
when the children and her family
orphaned almost when almost grown meat
at Hampton Court
Virginia sees that each of them is a
petal of one flower the implosion across
the Atlantic and deep into our continent
more than half a century later outside
the red rocker dome was something like
that though the scruffy meadow in
southern southern Colorado was less
genteel than the manicured gardens of
Hampton Court and our realization was on
a sloppy Stone jumbo American scale it's
one of the moments I think of when
people ask what
was it like to be there what were we
doing there but it's one I've never told
them about last night I had a dream of a
memory or maybe it was a memory of a
dream or a dream about a dream nearly
over even then the actual moment and
last night's glimpse of it were brief
but I've shared that flawed and fleeting
vision with the children of the where
photo ever since and it makes a
difference
okay now we'll just have a random
extremely random selection of slides
they kind of all fell out on the way up
so here we go this is TP living
approximately December about 9,000 feet
when we were building her house which we
had started in June but it hadn't really
moved along as quickly as we'd planned
this is the rock around which we decided
to build our house it's quite large and
those are the Sangre de Cristo's behind
it you can see how far the houses at
Libre were from each other there's a
zone down below
another geodesic kind of form
we had an eight-sided house there were
eight logs which we placed we dynamited
the holes for and placed uprights and
had eight figures and we're on to vigas
at this point i think we've got up to
four now and there's a little snow on
the mountain a lot of times we were
above the clouds the wherefore no valley
was a place the indians never came
except in the summer to hunt i think we
should have taken a clue in some ways
more snow on the wahoo Toya's this is a
log run up on the top of greenhorn
mountain we took logs that had already
been felled by loggers
this wasn't we hadn't measured it quite
right but it did go in eventually at a
certain point we realized we should just
wedge in a piece of the pie and make it
through the winter so that's what that
wall is that's the section of the pie
that had gotten built and walled in and
then we kept building even though we had
a place that was somewhat enclosed lots
of progress this is the upper we're
always building when it snows seem like
yes it seemed like a good time to get
things enclosed this is an upper room
and the deck more progress there's no
snow there
there's a lot of snow there it wasn't
quite the windows weren't in in the
upper room yet
but the windows were in here it's an
interiors you the kitchen area
lots of lofts to the the rap was on a
slope so the downhill section of the
house had very high ceilings whereas the
back section had lower ceilings
this is our garden in June this is Pat
who's here tonight
she had this baby in her teepee tawa
I think that's Pablo in the upper right
some red rockers Peter Mumford and Pat
there are a lot of children here this is
taya the baby that was born in the
teepee and it was the leo birthday party
taya and bilk adele were both Leo's
you're gonna have to help me with some
names
[Music]
Larry red rocker this is the Libre
school yeah
we had school in different houses every
day this was Bill Hybels house and he
hadn't quite finished it either
this is Linda someone who lives at leap
Libre she's now a professor at the
College of Fine Arts in San Francisco
Dean and one of his paintings another
inhabitant of Libre in fact someone who
still leaves it lives at Libre and
never was there I think the first day it
was purchased and is there now hey run
with a mandala pick up I mean flatbed
Lars and Linda Lars was from the Triple
A Adrian a mechanic from the Triple A
some red rockers along with
this is a neighborhood they bring
rancher who attended our parties often
and often ended up looking like this I
don't understand he always got in a
crouch he just was always it was just he
didn't fall over he just and it was
usually right by the beer keg this is
Karina red rocker at her birthday party
Larry and Vicki red rocker some children
Elaine is also here tonight
some red rocker women um the triple a
band Trixie I think that was at Mary's
house
it's Jack Trixie to focus maybe it was
maybe I was out of focus okay we'll move
on another birthday party picture of
Korea
we had a lot of parties perhaps why
that's why the house didn't get built it
is fast and you children this is our
medical staff Leon's second from right
and may holding the baby where our
doctors it's another picture of Lance
Trixie Clark another member was that
stuck
okay
a Thanksgiving shot at the red rockers
[Music]
elektra another child where's that
that's me
this is a Risha another child with
children they they all look so wonderful
in these pictures and they were David
this is AG for Chrome and it didn't
behave well over the years unfortunately
and the lights are on this was where
fan-out pops at the red rocker dome
that's Adrienne in the doorway of her
her house another house under
construction view from the Wehrman house
which was the house that was under
construction more snow
this was Libra in 1970 Jim Fowler's
house and that's it constructed
Tony in Maryland at Libra and their dome
this is the interior dome shot Pat's
house another view of Pat's house the
library this is the Okies house instead
of building a house around the rock they
built a house in between the rugs but
they didn't last too long this is a some
chimes I believe marked a Subaru funded
help fund maybe this was the bus that no
maybe another view of the Libre from the
ridge this is a picture of the last
supper that Steve and a friend put on
their van and drove across country I'm
not sure they could do it today
I think the Dove is broken up I never
noticed anything the piano and painted
and for a while we were into painting
heraldic shields and this is Dana and
Linda's heraldic shield that's that's
Peter rabbits this is a pager pegging
Jim Fowler did of liebre another few
houses
this is Peter Orlovsky a longtime
companion of an Ginsberg when he was
visiting liebre - the lights are too
high to see it's Gregory Corso he was
also along that's Gregory Corso um Peter
velocity and Allen Ginsberg and various
Libre
it's Peter Orlovsky again chopping away
makes me nervous and they're just a few
shots of the valley
Thanks
I have thousands of slides and I rifled
through them pretty quickly trying to
find some from people who are from the
Denver area and I wish I'd had a little
more time a little cross-eyed I just did
a reading on flew up here and did an
interview on Colorado Public Radio and
okay this is a chapter that stated
September 1970 and it's called visitors
our most recent visitor Jean Claude has
stayed with us for a week
he's a thin frail French student has
been traveling around the American West
Jean Claude gets up very early in the
morning and before we can stop him he
uses half a pound of coffee to make a
pot that is so strong David and I can't
drink it Jean Claude drinks it all
himself at breakfast and then goes back
to bed with severe stomach pains for a
few hours in the afternoon he staggers
over in his espadrilles to help us at
the site but he bends about half the
nails he hammers and we have to pull
them out which takes much longer than
hammering them in without his help he
shakes so much from drinking coffee and
chain smoking Gauloises that there's
little chance he can hammer a nail and
straight he drops his end of each log at
least once when removing it late in the
day he collapses against a rock and
regards the mountain ranges exclaiming
ah c'est magnifique
by then were happy he's not trying to
help the II Ching says that to overcome
the chaos of new beginnings it's very
important not to be alone that you need
helpers I don't question this but lately
I've been wondering about the kinds of
helpers who show up since Doug David's
brother left to finish his last year of
high school were a bit desperate for
help and we don't have a big selection
the saner stronger well-heeled visitors
the ones who drive up the road in new
four-wheel drives
snagged by those on the lower part of
the land it's the factory seconds who
get up on the ridge like john claude we
didn't mind him at first David and I
love Gaddar the fact that John caught
his French made him sophisticated
attractive and that uh though it was
clear he was no John Henry or Zsa Hari
we'd hoped he'd catch on after a while
it's wonderful that a stranger who grew
up 8,000 miles away can walk up to our
summer kitchen and will automatically
welcome him the message needs to spread
across the world he's young and
inquisitive and he's taken the trouble
to get here his hairs long and he smokes
dope that's all a member of the
worldwide secret society of youth that's
bigger than anything before bigger than
the Mafia the Masons the Communist Party
the Underground Railroad jean-claude
however has cast doubt on his membership
standing in the new movement and
outlasted the benefits of our doubts I'm
not so sure he's really one of us he has
no interest in making a significant
contribution to our cause another
problem is that his English isn't very
good and it gets a lot worse when you
ask him to work even if you pantomime
that you want him to go get a bag of
cement or wash the dishes he doesn't get
it yesterday morning I screwed up my
courage and said jean-claude when are
you going to move on he didn't
understand so I raised my voice out of
the embarrassing American conviction
that foreigners understand you better
when you yell but also in exasperation
when are you going to leave calm de
parte vous so much for hands across the
ocean he ignored my French although my
accents pretty good and said oh I would
like to leave here forever last night
we hid the coffee this morning as
jean-claude stumbled around the summer
kitchen groggily looking for it I
screwed up my courage and told him over
and over he had to go in English and
French
go get out aller Vata he was horribly
insulted and suffering from massive
caffeine withdrawal he ran around
yelling in French too fast for me to
understand almost crying gathering up
his books and belongings and flopped
down the hill and his torn espadrilles I
had to hold myself back from stopping
him and apologizing I felt horrible why
do I have to be the one to evict these
guys David hates confrontations and
never seems to my mind these losers as
much as I do
the German TV crew were a better sort of
European visitor they didn't work much
but when Peter suggested they buy a few
kegs of beer in exchange for filming us
for their documentary about communes in
the States they quickly read got
directions to Janie and Danny winces and
took off in their new rental van
later that afternoon we drank the beer
on Dean and Linda's front porch and
explained what we were doing in the
where photo the Sun set as we wash down
our words with more beer I don't know if
the film will give an accurate picture
of what we're doing but it was great to
have a free cold beer after work we live
in a bizarre repressed intolerant
society there are self-sufficient and
helpful visitors of course Stewart Brand
the founder of the Whole Earth Catalog
drives up towing his air Airstream
trailer parks and Dean and Linda's
meadow and sits out in his lawn chair
and chats dr. Frank who just happens to
be visiting a shortly after Patricia has
her baby probably saves Patricia's life
by diagnosing an infection and
immediately driving her and the infant
up to a Denver hospital but for every
visitor who contributes to our endeavor
there are 50 who suck us dry where the
destination of hopeless crazy youth the
last stop before a mental institution
for some first there was crazy John who
was big and strong and helped for
while but lost it and started mumbling
to himself and sneaking back to the
summer kitchen and eating everything
over at the Red Rocks he busted the lock
on the kitchen trailer one night and ate
and ate some hunger deep inside him
couldn't be satisfied when the Red
rockers kicked him out he went home and
the next time he came through we noticed
his underwear on the clothesline had a
state institution stamp he was more
subdued but not better off then there
was Marty Maya nobody knows his real
name a 17-year old high school dropout
who arrived here during the driest part
of the summer before the first rainy
season the day Dean got back from Japan
he smelled smoke and ran up the ridge to
find Marty feeding a big fire under a
semicircle of five tinder dry dead
pinions
Dean barely got the fire out
frantically kicking it apart and
throwing dirt on it while Marty stood
around protesting that it was an altar
to the Sun Goddess he'd been ordered to
build what about the rain goddess Dean
asked we don't need any more Sun we
think Richard and best quiet visitor
Joel shot at us last week when we were
working something pinged off the rock
very near us a few times before David
and I realized it was a bullet and
ducked behind the boulder like The Lone
Ranger and Tonto and an ambush when we
went up to confront him
Richard explained that joel was shooting
at a target behind Richard and best
sight on the quest but that didn't make
sense
the bullets couldn't possibly have
ricocheted from there to our house site
there was no trajectory that could get a
bullet from the cliffs to our house
Richard took Joel's gun away Ben and
chapito came up from New Mexico Ben was
a member of the [ __ ] a street
kid from the New York's Lower East Side
and he and chapito got together back
then they have six horses in a teepee
now and we're riding north to Canada
from New Mexico but the where fanaa was
as far as they got before Ben came down
with dysentery
so they pitched their tepee in the
lowest part of the land near Tony and
Maryland's dome where Ben lay on animal
skins and entertained visitors and
chapitre ran around hunting cooking
cleaning chopping wood feeding and
shoeing the horses she'd be a
eight visitor to have around I invited
them up the ridge but right after that
their horses got into the libre garden a
second time and been got religion at one
of John Pedro's peyote meetings so they
moved to the upper land of the Horta
bees farm one guy from California came
and stayed for two weeks smoking
cigarettes angrily as he worked keeping
to himself not saying much when he left
he told us Libre was hopelessly
bourgeois but he asked lots of questions
about where we got our dynamite after
him there was Karl a graduate school
friend of mine now dealing rare books in
London he was a bit overweight with pale
skin no muscle tone and a frizzy afro
but he meant well he helped David carry
some 5-gallon cans of water up the ridge
sweating profusely
Roberta karl said panting like a bulldog
I've figured it out what I asked
wondering how young a person could be
and still have a heart attack I was
trying to recall the techniques I'd
learned when I got my senior lifesaver
badge at camp I said you know Karl it's
9,000 feet higher here than it is in New
York or London you really ought to take
it easy you were a princess in a past
life or assault ins favorite daughter
thousands of servants incredibly rich
clothes silks jewels like what they took
for the English crown jewels now in this
lifetime you're working off karma on
this mountain living this hard life to
make up for the luxuries and decadence
of your past lives karl said between
deep sucking gasps he was a funny shade
of pink with a lot of blue in it do you
think there's any way I could switch
back to that previous life I cracked
I'm skeptical about past lives
everyone's had a royal one no one was a
servant or slave or an average peasant
maybe I'm just working off my privileged
life in this lifetime I said to Karl but
didn't go on he needed to save his
breath body Karl's girlfriend who was a
graduate school with us at Buffalo - she
wrote on Jane Austen was a good visitor
until the afternoon she found a field
mouse Kachina had murdered and left for
me on a shelf in the summer kitchen
Bonnie screamed it's the Middle Ages and
wasn't interested when I explained about
the loyalty of Siamese cats that the
mouse carcass was a gift Kachinas way of
demonstrating her love for me or maybe
her concern that I'm not getting enough
to eat Bonnie and Carl left the next day
and it's probably for the best
they missed going down to Gardner with
us to visit clawed his wife and their
newborn Claude made a buff Bergen young
types - out of a placenta he said some
tribe or other believed that eating it
brought great good fortune after he told
us what was in this dude David pushed it
around his plate diplomatically but I
went outside and threw up I hate to say
this but are there any questions yes in
my young boyhood I lived in a ranch
right near the area just short of
Redwing uh-huh and I had been back in
the area many years since but as an
adult that came back when I came back
from Vietnam this is my grandmother Adam
in uniform and my ribbons my gold jump
wings and I take the truck and I'm
driving out to write and I come back
past your place and I think what the
hell is this I get out and I walk over
there I'm just awestruck and because the
uniform ever walks out in there
awestruck where did you come from it's
like these two alien creatures but it's
each other and we didn't talk for about
a minute
he was just gawking you know so I was
curious how did you end up at that site
for me and my life it was you know
ranching and take care of animals in the
land that kind of thing how did I end up
how did that site become developed like
that the the holy Bray right um I
believe for people Dean and Linda and
Peter and Judy his wife we're looking
for some land Peter had been at drop
city and it had been too close to the
road and toover overrun by the types of
visitors I've just described and there
had been many problems and they were
looking for a place to start a community
and so they went to some realtors in
Wallenberg the Thatch's and found this
spot of land looked at many spots of
land but found the spot of land any
other questions
just passed down over the years and the
same people own it or the whole
community has owned it or how it's only
very corporation and the corporation
consists of the people who live there
they've recently changed the bylaws to
include some of the children that you
saw pictures now of who are now young
adults and don't don't live there all
the time
but it's a nonprofit corporation it was
a school for a long time because so many
people had degrees any other questions
yes very high degrees yes Dean Fleming
the the only person living there that
was part of it around eight people
living there now Jim Fowler who was
there very early on is there several
people who were there back in the time
I'm writing about were there and some
people come back in the summer and stay
there who have jobs and lives in other
parts of the country very new and
expensive modern architecture that's in
there in terms of them we roam CIA at
that area there that's what I heard from
David Perkins this last summer they do
some new architecture I might like brand
new homes that are not less a what would
you say not hippie hippie dwellings but
rather I don't know about that and I may
not be a with it I think they've all
been refined expensive architecture I
don't think so
these are occurring - oh the Newton holy
Barry maybe he's thinking at cauldros
not at Libre though I don't think that's
correct for those of you who are
interested there's a retrospective of
Dean's painting set Sangre de Cristo Art
Center this summer in Pueblo well this
winter February 11 February
three months any other questions
you're a lot easier than the Colorado
Public Radio yeah I'm curious you were
there how many years um about six and a
half how did and why did you leave well
you just have to read that it was just
time for me to move on but it I felt
that the war was over Carter was in the
White House it was a whole different
political atmosphere I'd had a wonderful
time in many ways there but I was
interested in returning to the
marketplace I guess I went down to Santa
Fe and lived in Santa in the fall of
1977 shortly after Ginsberg was they're
describing libras heaven on earth and an
article I think of in the Sun Boulder
alternative paper and stayed at a
friend's house and eventually ended up
the way many people with PhDs
in Santa Fe do work in a restaurant and
then sort of segwayed into ending up
going to law school in 1980 in
Albuquerque did your parents think of
your lifestyle
well you'll have to read they they were
they were Rockefeller Republicans which
I guess is probably more left than Bill
Clinton was but um they they didn't
understand at all on the other hand they
loved me and they visited my brother
visited my cousins visited and they I
don't think they were supportive you
know but they weren't they didn't try to
dissuade me from doing it I have to
credit them being a parent now of a
seventeen year old I have more sympathy
from for their experience yes lots of
visitors were your brother and cousins
was well my brother was very helpful in
his own way he was very impatient and
liked to get things done which was kind
of a new approach and my cousins were
there so briefly that they really just
were in and out I think I got the award
for the most family members there's a
lot of themes in the book having to do
with family a family you're born with in
the family you choose so you to write
the book did you keep journals or um
let's see I've got a grant from Vassar
to take a year off from practicing law
called the timeout grant which was a
wonderful gift I had been trying to
write it while I practiced law and I had
a son fairly young son and husband who
was very busy very busy lawyer and an
older stepson and a dog and a bird and
anyway I thought that I could sort of
just you know the way William Carlos
Williams would see patients and then
write a poem and then see a patient but
he was a genius and he lived in a
different age and
I didn't get very far and then I applied
for this grant called a timeout grant
and I pretty much did it in the year I
had done a few chapters before but I
realized I only had this year and I also
got a grant from the Wurlitzer
Foundation and they gave me a place to
write for a couple of months I would
they're located in cows and they gave me
a little Adobe to write in and so and
they were also very understanding many
artists come from across the country and
stay there but they knew I lived in
Albuquerque and I said I'm going to come
up there and stay three or four days a
week so I pretty much got the first
draft done in that grant year when and
really it was 11 months because the I
had chosen to sort of wind down my
practice and start in October out of
September 2001 which as you all remember
was a difficult time serve for about a
month I was just sort of saying what is
the point of writing about something
like this in the face of what's just
happened and then I sort of I guess
moved into a sort of spirit of defiance
I am going to write about all the stupid
stuff so there is llama you know
whatever and anyway so I I could have
taken longer I but I I knew I only had
that time and I did but not too much of
a rewrite but I I cut it down quite a
bit
publishers wasn't willing to publish it
in the length it was so I did a lot
everything I had pretty much written at
the time but I just cut it down a great
deal over the next and I was working but
uh in the next year what do you recall
as your most difficult challenge or task
of everyday living during that time
it changed from season to season I think
staying warm was a big challenge a lot
of the time but you know it's hard to
categorize in that way I don't have a
good answer for you it was we were all
so young and we had decided to do this
and so we just got up and said oh okay
we're in a teepee the water cans are
frozen we're oh well you know that kind
of thing and I think one of the hardest
challenges was everybody had come there
pursuing it perhaps a different dream
and when those dreams collided or didn't
mesh it that was a challenge
my husband says hey why don't we just go
no I haven't I haven't in fact uh and I
visited I've gone back and it's
beautiful I love it but I I I haven't
thought of I think of that as a
wonderful time but not a place I need to
return to in your 20s to live that
rugged and lifestyle yes that's right
you know we were really brave we didn't
have any money and you didn't have a
house and you had your kids and teepees
and you did all this stuff I don't think
we could do that now
I don't want sure I couldn't do it I
have a doctor Frank one of the
characters in the book is a doctor now
in Montana and we were going to go up
and visit him and he said you know I
even have a teepee pitched out by the
river you could stay in and I said what
are you talking about then sort of been
there done that
yes what did you do to earn money in
order to continue for those seven years
we did many different things we had a
bill Cadell one of the characters in
there had a construction crew so we
worked construction the band I'm not
sure the band broke even but they played
a lot a lot of people left in the winter
and had jobs elsewhere and got some
money together I mean the whole concept
living in America's economy was very
different it really was pretty easy to
live off the fat of the land David was
at one reading in Santa Fe and said he
calculated that really the building
materials for our house cost about $600
you know the reject railroad ties that
were the walls cost $10 $5 a truckload
we scrounged tongue and groove flooring
from the dance halls from Rockefellers
coal mine towns we got lots of metal
pieces from the
Mines we bought lots of things
secondhand we were given things people
many people were on food stamps you just
said was impossible it was a it was the
poorest County in Colorado I don't know
if it still is it Rhea and so there were
a lot of people who are unemployed I
mean it was a hard I was in a movie and
anybody else have any other additions
your 17 year old kid what does he really
believe all this or does he think it's a
movie you know like many 70 year olds I
don't think he thinks much beyond his
own life which is probably good he said
to me the other day I mean I did ask him
the editor really wanted to put this
picture on the cover as soon as he saw
it and I was resisted and he kept saying
show me another picture little sell
books and I kept showing him pictures
and I didn't come up with anything that
he thought was better but at any rate I
asked my son if it was alright to have
this picture on the cover of the book
and he said I'm a senior I'll be halfway
through my senior year I'll get a lot of
grief but I can take it and then and
then after one reading he said do you
should I read the book and I said well
why don't you wait too you're older and
he said okay you know it's really I
don't think he's really that interested
you know yeah yeah yeah at some point he
might be not the my older stepson who's
in his 30s was much more interested and
says he was very proud of us for doing
what we decided to do and just following
through on whatever crazy idea we
latched onto he didn't say it was crazy
he he and his age group are much more
admiring what I've been surprised at is
how much I mean I thought this would be
a baby boomer kind of audience but what
I've been surprised at is how many
20 to 30 year olds have have been really
interested in it and enthusiastic about
it how much contact did you have with
the towns and what kind of contact was
that well we you know went into town
often I think it was the highlight of
her days and unlike some of the areas in
New Mexico I think by and large the
local people were pretty welcoming
towards us and very helpful the where
for now is as far north as the Spaniards
ever got when they colonized but
nevertheless there were penitentes in
the valley and and and children who
people who had been children during the
great coalfield Wars which were the wars
between the minors and Rockefellers coal
mines to see if I tonight in which
george mcgovern calls it the blackest
page in American social history so some
of those people had been children and
had been children and miners and were
taken up into the mountains when things
got too hot but they remembered
shootouts in the street of Wallenberg
and and I think they so they had a
perspective on American mainstream
America that perhaps other people and
other parts of the country didn't have
but some of my most valuable experiences
came from interacting with some of those
people
how large was your community when you
left I think Libra was about 25 when it
when I when I left and I I think the
population in the valley had maybe
dwindled a bit but there were still new
people coming in but it had dwindled
from that high point that I talked about
in the prologue many people had left
before before I did I kind of hung on
what do you like about living there what
did I like about living there I think
the the opportunity to live in that kind
of geography is is a really for someone
who grew up in the East Coast and only
saw the west on the Lone Ranger and
hoppy and I think some people respond
differently to geography and that
particular ability to get up every
morning or just stop what you're doing
and be able to see 60 miles was a a
wonderful opportunity and it was a
wonderful opportunity to just per just
sort of live out some dreams you had and
that sense of unlimited possibility is
sort of what I tried to to capture no
one's asked why I wrote the book but I'm
going to tell you anyway and that I felt
that that so much that has been written
about that time as sort of ridiculed and
marginalized and caricatured and sort of
just sort of made turned it into a joke
and it certainly there was a lot of
funny things happening and you did have
to have a sense of humor but I also
thought there was something else that
made us do something that crazy that
hadn't been had been expressed and I
felt a certain amount of disappointment
and I'm sure everybody here who lived in
the where if and what when you see some
documentaries on TV or
or read some things that's kind of you
know everyone's sort of saying wow it
was really great man it's just great you
know and it's like and and and many of
us went on to do many different things
and have very rich and enjoyable lives
right now but the the sense of the
excitement and youthful folly and
enthusiasm I didn't I didn't see or
didn't feel people understood at one
time there were three million people
about my age in rural communes and in
the United States and there were as the
estimate was there were 3,000 rural
communes and everybody my age knows how
many urban communal experiments there
were so was you know it was a
significant number of people and and not
just a sort of lunatic fringe or maybe a
lunatic majority we shouldn't start up
something like this again for senior
well it certainly it certainly is being
talked about yes I read about and
different different people are doing
that of course with my experience when
my friends say hey let's all you know
it's like wait a minute stop yeah
different wonderful we got to have a
really extended um adolescence right and
we got to you know it like I watch the
kids who want to be artists right now in
America you pay 750 for rent you aren't
going to get to make much art you're
gonna hustle waitressing or what do we
have to do to make that rent we had a
free place to live and you know I became
a weaver then and a builder and you be
what you wrote and other people did
their art and it end it was a school of
life I mean you learned that a water
pumps push water further than they'll
pull you know Joe Nardini teaches you
that a ton Fugs
and you know you learn all these
somebody said whoa don't you wish you
hadn't wasted your time I said are you
kidding we learned so much we did we did
I think they asked me on the radio today
do you have any regrets and that really
you know that's a valley perhaps we
should have built our house and we'll
you know closer to water something it
maybe not have just done hundred-percent
view that's the criteria but I just
perhaps it's a it's another indication
of our that that generation that I just
don't think in terms of regrets
Lars when he was real sick and dying and
he said Pat we are such lucky humans to
have been so intimate with so many
people and really saw how the human
nature ticked or we were pretty tikki
but but you know he really enjoyed that
fact that we were all so close well it
is kind of remarkable and it I do feel
in a certain sense that perhaps other
generations and the generation I I know
my sons both my sons friends and they're
remarkable and in many ways much better
adjusted because they were raised by us
but but and more mature but but
nevertheless I feel in a way that they
just didn't have that opportunity for
example when I found out I was coming up
to Denver
I called some people here who from the
where for know who I haven't been in
regular contact with I haven't spoken to
some for 20 years and it was like when
are you coming what's got dinner you can
stay at my house and that's pretty much
true of anywhere you go where there's
somebody from that time not everyone
I want to say that that particular
generation or my generation had a
certain idealism about what could be and
dreaming about possibilities and
breaking through American individualism
into a more communal sense and my
daughter Paloma who is studying at
Carlton called me on Martin Luther
King's birthday and she was in a
political class where the professor
asked the students if they were realist
or idealist and all the students except
for her said they were realist and she
said today's Martin Luther King's
birthday how can you not be an idealist
how can not believe in dreams and I
think there's a whole generation of
people today that don't have that
ability to think I can do I can dream I
can create a future that's different
than what exists today and I think
that's an important thing that that our
generation did is that we believed that
we could change the world and whatever
way we wanted to do it
I'd like to somewhat echo her sense of
idealism I think everybody from that
generation is all absolutely convict
sure of one conviction and that's that
we stopped the Vietnam War and we have
another opportunity to stop another war
now what blanket time what about all the
casualties what about all the drug use
were about all the alcoholism what about
our lack of skillful means in dealing
with each other the harm that we caused
there there's no denying that you know I
couldn't possibly dream to explain that
away that but you know when I moved away
from Weber and I moved to a redneck
village I felt like a woman without a
country for a long time and what I what
I started to understand is we were a
microcosm and you go to any microcosm
there are casualties I mean straight
people have drug problems have alcohol
problems they have deaths in their
family
I remember when Leah died
Dean was saying how cruel the mountain
was I said Dean if we were in New York
or knowing the McNabb boys had that car
wreck I said if we were in New York you
wouldn't know the McNab's
that far away out of your neighborhood
in New York it was just there was so
much impotent a'mma see that because
there were so few of us that every time
you met a human they were important to
you because you're so lonesome that we
saw that stuff more I don't think it was
any different than any straight society
I think perhaps it might have been more
extreme in every way extreme and it's
ideal as an extreme in its abuse extreme
in its emotions there was a lot of
untrammeled untrammeled well this this
is how I feel so this is how it is and
that kind of kind of thing but I I don't
think that the fact that there were
casualties should should completely mask
the fact that there was some idealistic
good things and a lot of love happening
at the same time so certainly I haven't
tried to mask it over I mean I you can
only put so much in it that people keep
reading you know but I haven't tried to
I've at least tried to put in some of
those issues
and and it was a place as I said in the
chapter I read that people that didn't
have anywhere else to go went and they
were often very unhappy and and and
mentally disturbed people and so they
they arrived there too and played out
their drama and I I'm not sure you can
fault the idealistic dream that's that
appealed to everybody the better part of
everybody with the fact that it
attracted people who had nowhere else to
go nowhere else that would tolerate them
being to accept everybody to remember I
mean yours ideals to love it I had a
hard time with it I know finally you
said geez or just some people I can't
stand
hey it was a real light bulb moment I
think there's someone over here that
needs the boom down there is now that
land of selling for thousands dollars an
acre and there's still no water Hey yes
I was sort of wondering that you know
like in your day-to-day you know trying
to earn a living and just survive did
people really appreciate the here and
now like the sunrises of sunsets or they
could take time off and you know like go
wow you know yes I think I think I'm not
sure everyone saw the Sun Rise
but certainly even when we were working
and the blizzard might be coming but we
really didn't have any weather reports I
mean when it was sunset we sat and
watched the sunset it was the best show
part of the land I think that's why
everybody put up with what they put up
with I think that's one of the reasons I
can't venture to say why everybody put
up with what they put up with but that
was one reason I put up with a lot when
I went through what you're describing
and it's really nice to touch the past
but we our theme song was wooden ships
you know you don't want us we're leaving
goodbye and it was fine with us so I
don't know what our theme song was I
haven't thought about that I don't think
we had a theme song if you're a hippie
on a Saturday night you'll never be
straight again when you asked about the
tragedies and stuff like I have a lot of
young kids that work for me now and like
I watched their love affairs and they're
just brutal and I just think oh god I'm
so glad I'm not young going through that
I mean you know young people are more
brutal and self-centered you know at
probably in our 50s we'd be a lot
gentler to each other I mean there
really was a lot of emotional pain and
people trumping on each other's
heartstrings you know and I think that
also has to do with youth and the kind
of youth that